the holidays are great but they can have
some negative effects on your health
p3 healthcare is breaking down how to
stay well during this time
we're talking about staying healthy
physically and mentally during the
holidays
especially as we enter that winter blue
season right
absolutely absolutely so seasonal
affective disorder
is uh basically a seasonal depression
that happens when there's a decrease in
the daylight hours
it happens all across the spectrum from
young adults all the way to our seniors
unfortunately our seniors are especially
vulnerable to it
because they have a lot of chronic
health conditions as many as 80 percent
of them have uh
chronic health conditions so they're uh
especially uh vulnerable to it uh some
of the signs and symptoms can include
loss of interest in things that you used
to like to do
uh feelings of sadness feelings of
hopelessness
fatigue just a generalized fatigue and
even some anxiety
definitely i feel like the current
conditions we have now with the pandemic
might
heighten that as well right absolutely
um
you know we're all a lot socially
isolated
uh and so it's important to uh reach out
uh if you can't connect with someone
physically video calls
just picking up the telephone what can
be done to prevent this seasonal
depression especially
for our elderly community yeah that's a
great question
so exposing yourself to as much sunlight
as possible the sun comes out really
early so if you could wake up a little
bit early
go walk the dog connect with nature
and exercise is always really really
helpful
we recommend at least 30 minutes a day
or as tolerated
why is it important though to be
cautious about holiday food
it's important to uh you know watch the
amount of foods that you're eating
kind of break it up into smaller meals
instead of eating those
real big large meals and just really
going for it and really over indulging
so not piling the plate up this high
not piling the plate up as high you
could maybe go back a couple of times
but you know smaller portions would
definitely be helpful
i will keep that in mind thank you and
what are some of those um ways to create
a healthier
healthier meal this holiday season
halfing the the amount of sugar that a
recipe calls for
uh so if it calls for one cup of sugar
maybe try using half a cup of sugar
alternatively you could use uh fresh
fruits
uh or frozen fruits that don't have
added sugar or salt
are some really good ways that you could
reduce on that sugar
um also using different spices
instead of trying to salt things up uh
use vanilla
nutmeg cinnamon different spices to add
the flavor
and without adding a lot of that sodium
trying to avoid also those heavy uh
salt condiments like mustard ketchup
pickles
i'll try to use fresh tomatoes salsa
uh you know different things like that
would really be helpful
and then if a recipe calls for whole
milk uh try to use skim milk or one
percent
would definitely be a better alternative
great information for more information
on this topic and on p3 health care
call 702 333 4700
or visit p3nv.org
las vegas now we'll be right back